I feel like the u.s. right now is in
more of a position to need help then
offer it you know it seems like we still
have massive shortages of testing and
PPE yeah do you think that China has an
opportunity to genuinely fill that
vacuum you know I think that the United
States if we wanted to do more we
certainly could you're right Andrew that
today we we lack tests but in six months
time twelve months time that this debate
is not going to be about medical supply
chain it's going to be about getting the
global economy back moving and a whole
bunch of developing countries are gonna
desperately need aid and we've got the
deep pockets so there will be a question
of the IMF the World Bank others are the
Americans gonna step up with our allies
because the Chinese are not gonna do
much there's still a comparatively poor
country where I think the Chinese have a
real advantage is the fact that you and
I are sitting here talking about this in
the teeth of this crisis and the Chinese
economy's already restarted because they
have a surveillance state they have a
technologically empowered authoritarian
system which has allowed them to
quarantine people to get a hundred
percent compliance and to control the
rebuilding of their supply chain getting
it up and running when the Americans and
the Europeans are still shut down and
deeply politically conflicted about how
and when we will restart it and I think
that that ability of the Chinese to show
countries maybe some countries that
don't care quite as much about democracy
but really want to get their economies
going hey look at what we're doing with
technology look at what we're doing with
surveillance look what we're doing with
data wouldn't you like to have your
economy rebuilt like that and by the way
that'll also give you the government a
lot more control of your population
they'll be much more quiescent they'll
be much more loyal I worry that there
are countries out there in Southeast
Asia in sub-saharan Africa in East and
southern Europe even in Latin America
that will find that model more appealing
America won't
Germany won't but it's getting harder
when the average American doesn't
believe in the American dream and the
average Chinese does believe in the
Chinese dream which is what she's in
paying uses right when he tries to
really gain patriotism in China we've
got a problem in convincing others
around the world that you should follow
us